We have good news. This is good news from the
standpoint of being less bad. US Weekly new
jobless claims are at their lowest level
since the start of. The coronavirus pandemic,
there was a bigger than expected drop in new
unemployment claims that we learned about
yesterday, we are at a pandemic era low. The
Department of Labor released this information
yesterday morning. The new jobless claims
for the week ending March 20 came in at six
hundred and eighty four thousand. The expectation
was seven hundred and thirty thousand and the
revised expectation was seven hundred and eighty
one thousand. So almost one hundred thousand fewer
initial jobless claims than expected over
the last week. Continuing claims are down to
three point eight million, three point eight
million remaining unemployed versus the four
million and four point one million that were
expected and revised. This is the first time new
jobless claims have been under 700000, going back
to mid-March of twenty twenty, which is the start
of the pandemic. And really, you know, week to
week, the numbers can kind of go up and down what
we want to look at as trends and new lows. And we
are seeing both the continuing downward trend and
a new low. Now, this is not a while. Everything's
fixed. That's fantastic. It's not that at all.
And we still have so many different issues,
including jobs that are coming back as part
time that used to be full time. And what's funny
is the when when a Democrat is in the White House,
the right always says they're not telling
you this and this and this and this.
But I tell you this stuff all the time.
There's reasons that these numbers are not
glorious numbers. And this only has some to
do with Joe Biden accelerating vaccination,
certainly as a factor. But there is a seasonality
to this pandemic that is similar in much of the
world. You know, I have no interest in making
things partizan when they don't particularly
need to be. There's no doubt that there are
some jobs coming back as part time rather
than full time. As businesses go from being open
a little bit to being fully open, hopefully in
the next six months, some of those part time
jobs will become full time. They won't all
all all sorts of other caveats. We've not
dealt with the minimum wage. There are still
wage issues in general. But I think if we are
looking to kind of take a cautiously optimistic
approach on the pandemic, yesterday we saw
that although cases have stopped declining,
hospitalizations are still declining, albeit
more slowly. Deaths are still declining
and vaccinations are increasing. If we think two
to three months out as we get into early summer,
that's potentially a pretty good looking
situation economically. We are now starting
to get new analyzes from Goldman Sachs. And I
know many people will say, David, Goldman Sachs,
if you go back to the Goldman Sachs analyzes of
April twenty twenty in terms of vaccine rollout
and economic numbers, they were the most accurate
I'm aware of. They correctly predicted approval
for a vaccine in late October, early November.
They correctly predicted that you would start to
see health care workers vaccinated towards the end
of 2020. Trump was saying it would be way sooner.
Some doom and gloom ers were saying
it wouldn't be under until the middle
of twenty twenty one. Goldman Sachs has been
excellent on this with their predictions. I'm not
telling you. Go and get Goldman financial adviser.
I'm not telling you anything about financial
advisors. But the Goldman analysis is that the end
of twenty twenty one, particularly Q4, is going to
look very good by most of the economic indicators
that that we look at. So the point here is much
work to be done, not the time to start going
crazy, as they've been doing in some spring break
hotspots. But the economic numbers are improving,
the vaccination numbers are improving, and
we're hoping that the blip in cases is going to
continue down over the next two to three months.
I am sure that I will get some calls from viewers
in the next segment about what is going on with
vaccination and the pandemic. Let me know your
thoughts on the expected trajectory. You can find
me on Twitter at David Pakman. And you can also
find the show on Twitter at David Pakman show.